I like my life that's Jen garner and
boyfriend John Miller leaving a sushi
date in Los Angeles earlier this week
and now a source close to Jen tells et
that things are getting serious between
the two and they couldn't be happier
our source says quote they're in a drue
honeymoon phase in their relationship
but adds while they've spoken about a
future together and neither of them are
ready to plan a wedding or get engaged
it's a big deal our source also says
John's great with Jen's kids adding that
they've taken them to the mountains
together so you love to camp like
camping with your family oh it's it's
crazy there's just so many books my kids
are always afraid they're gonna run out
of books mm-hmm so there's so they're
just it's like the tent is full we used
headlamps a lot in the show and my
family we also have a thing for
headlamps and we'll play headlamp tag
late at night it's just the feeling of
being up after dark and sitting around a
campfire
as for Jen's ex Ben Affleck he's still
very much in the family picture and they
are dedicated to co-parenting but the
amount of time she spends with him is
getting less frequent our source adds
jen has something in a very different
with John than she had with Ben she and
John are both interested in living a
healthy lifestyle working out and eating
well and dads Jenn is at a very healthy
point in her life she adores her kids
and her career and has fallen in love
with a man who was supportive and loving
to both her and the kids
[Music]